ja so ein video ich habe für ungefähr
zweieinhalb monaten gedacht hey wie wäre
es denn eigentlich wenn du mein eigenes
spielzeug finden würdest und dabei ist
dann der herumgekommen
zufälligerweise ist das dann eigentlich
eine bessere idee geboren als ich dachte
das habe ich eigentlich niemals vor
eigentlich sollte aber irgendwas
passieren nichtsdestotrotz ist es heute
an der zeit nochmal ein stückchen als
größeres zu machen und zwar ein eigenes
instrument zu erfinden wieder mit dem 3d
drucker und genau so funktioniert ein
instrumente irgendwas muss immer in
schwingungen versetzt werden egal ob das
der korpus einer gitarre durch das
zupfen ihrer seiten das fell eines
schlagzeugs durch die erschütterung mit
dem joystick oder die flöte ist die
durch die ihn durch fließende luft in
schwingungen gerät musik sind
schwingungen die unser trommelfell
erreichen wie auch besser als beim
finden des spielzeugs ist hier die
schwierigkeit etwas neues zu finden auf
dass das genie des menschen nicht
bereits zuvor gestoßen ist es gibt alles
kalimba marimba didgeridoo oder die pick
me flöte die nur einen einzelnen ton
kann und im zusammenspiel mit der stimme
des spielers funktioniert aber wenn es
das schon alles gibt kann ich dann
wirklich die nächste geige das nächste
schlagzeug oder den nächsten pass
erfinden nur eben das ist keine geige
schlagzeug oder war es sein darf sondern
etwas neues
dieses video wird unterstützt von skills
und was ich mir vorstellen könnte es
einmal ein zupfinstrument wie so eine
gitarre
jeder kennt man kann ein gummiband
nehmen und irgendein stück schnur und so
ja im prinzip kann damit alle mögen muss
gegen die geräusche macht musik machen
zb ein wagen stückchen metall hier
den ausgleich hatte jeder mit dem lineal
schon in der schule gemacht oder eine
säge zum beispiel und jetzt die frage
kann man mit all diesen spielereien also
zum beispiel mit diesem lineal dass man
irgendwann in der grundschule mal hier
so einen decks harz kann man ihm ein
funktionierendes spielbares instrument
machen mit jemand halbwegs gute musik
machen kann befinden raus ich glaube ich
habe eine idee ich glaube auch dass wir
das noch öfter hören werde weil wir
müssen recht viele sachen durch
probieren ist wir irgendwas halbwegs
brauchbares finden meine idee basiert
jetzt darauf also mal abgetan seiten
ich glaube hier würden reichen die kann
man dann mit einer hand spielen so die
gitarrensaiten sind dagegen die
befestigt man anstatt diese seiten jetzt
einfach so normal mit den fingern runder
zu drücken wie das bei einer gitarre der
fall ist hat man das mit so einem
kugellager darauf machen ja man hat das
teil dann so eine hand das soll nicht
besonders groß werden oder wieder diese
seiten des sohn teil wo man das hin und
her rutschen kann aber drunter ist hat
ein kugellager gleich los ist glaube ich
euch zeigen wo alles kompliziert
ich dachte am anfang das wird wieder
eine schnapsidee ist jedoch eine
schnapsidee aber ich habe richtig bock
auf des express richtigkeit meine
zeichnungen wollen und nehmen jetzt ein
bisschen abstrakt ich zeige euch diesmal
jetzt anhand von peking gitarre und euch
ein bisschen leichter zu zeigen eine
gitarre funktioniert dadurch meine seite
und dann immer drauf ja da der kanton
bern über eine gitarre gibt es ja so
richtig feste stufen das machen wir
nicht wir wollen es eher so wie man egal
wo das hat nicht diese stufen markt aber
nicht mit dem finger sondern mit so
einer art schieberegler hier oben wohnt
kugellager irgendwie smart eingebaut
wird und das dann hoffentlich so
funktioniert will dich bald an dem punkt
machen jetzt aber mal weiter am computer
weil die zeichnungen so ein bisschen
limitiert ich hab ein bisschen probleme
mir das dreidimensionale vorzustellen
auf dem papier deswegen würde ich sagen
warum gehen wir nicht direkt in den
dreidimensionalen raum weil ich selbst
noch keine ahnung hat wie das ding
aussehen soll deswegen habe ich jetzt
doch erst auf papier skizziert das
instrument hat eine abgerundete form und
soll relativ kleinen werden das gute
stück soll theoretisch mit einer hand
spielbar sein weswegen man ist am einen
ende zum beispiel mit klettverschluss an
der linken hand befestigen können soll
so würde es dann aussehen wenn man damit
spielt so aber jetzt warum gehen wir
nicht direkt in den dreidimensionalen
raum
[Musik]
den mechanismus der später auf mein
instrument gesetzt wird um die töne zu
kontrollieren entwerfe ich jetzt also in
3d bis sich das ganze also alle
einzelteile endlich fertig modelliert
habe vergehen ganze drei tage
[Musik]
wenn das jetzt ruft kümmere ich mich
schon mal um den auf die mechanismen der
saiten der gitarre ist es ja auch schon
je nachdem wie fest wenn diese seiten
zieht ändert sich auch die tonhöhe und
damit kann man das instrument am ende
stimmt hier funktioniert das mit so
einem schraubgewinde und im zahnrad aus
metall was dadurch natürlich extrem
stabil ist und die hohe zugkraft auch
aushält ich habe ja auch schon die maden
schrauben mit dem man so ein aufzug
mechanismus vielleicht machen könnte
dann brauche ich aber jetzt zusätzlich
noch so ein zahnrad aus dem baumarkt und
das möchte ich vermeiden so was jetzt
irgendwie aus plastik hinzukriegen ja
aus dem 3d drucker halte ich für relativ
schnell raus fordernd aber damit sagen
wir probieren es machen und dafür wollen
natürlich auch erst mal wieder eine
skizze und planen wir das überhaupt
funktioniert ich würde das auch einfach
dreist relativ ähnlich machen wie
deshalb weil eine gitarre auto fall ist
man hat hier einmal so ein bügel wo
diese seiten drüber laufen dann könnte
man das letzte cool abgestuften steht
ist das heute ein 1,18 okay die mach ich
das denn ein blödsinn weil so dick ist
das brett mit den nicht vorab den
grundkörper zu machen ja jetzt auch
nicht ja das war das einzige bretter
sich hier leider im büro rumliegen habe
genauso sogar das ganze instrument hier
kommt dann einmal so ein zylinder rein
auf denen wir das dann auch drehen kann
und genau hier soll dann so ein zahnrad
dran sein und dann hier daneben jetzt
mal so als kringe so eine schraube mit
der man das dann aufziehen kann ja ich
weiß nicht ob das funktioniert so eine
geballte ladung an material wir haben
aber die ganze bauteile hier einmal vier
schienen dann vier füße wir haben
zweimal die aufsätze aufs kugellager die
welt drauf setzen werden dann mal zwei
bolzen und 2 sind angehören wollten
andere halt dann hier einmal diese
halterungen und ich würde sagen wir
bereinigen die teile jetzt machen wir
machen diese unterstützungsstrukturen
weg weil logischerweise kann der 3d
drucker nicht einmal an den luftdruck
deswegen muss da wenn also eine kante
gemacht werden will ja logisch weil sie
ihr so dazwischen so ein bisschen
unterstützungsbeitrag gedruckt werden
dass man eine herauspicken müssen wir
mal gespannt ob dieser mechanismus jetzt
schon funktioniert die teile reichen
dafür aus angefangen kunden mit den
füßen
[Musik]
hier ist kein stück kaputtgegangen
das muss man neu drucken aber sie sind
zu dünn geworden vielleicht einmal zu
dünn gedruckt man vielleicht kann ich ja
für den prototypen jetzt mal trotzdem
testen alle teile die wir brauchen sind
fertig wir fangen direkt mit diesen
dingen da kommt jetzt quasi von unten
das da so das soll der einst leiten das
ist schon mal gut das funktioniert und
dass wir das ein bisschen friedlich
diesen bolzen reindrücken nur leider
muss man das halt machen nachdem es ein
bisschen zumindest
ok hat geklappt scheint sie funktioniert
mein gott sie können jetzt rücken und er
wurde nicht raus das ist eine
funktioniert endlich ein bisschen happy
meal qualität von damals war sitzt auch
wenn das am ende auch musik macht also
fertig sieht so aus jetzt schon mal die
eine rechte da kommen jetzt jeweils die
dinge rollen und dann kann man das so
drauf bauen sind und er mache jetzt dann
gleich das ding hier reinpasst an ihr
sohn wie der schiene halten trennen
gefangen sein wird da kommt dann grund
ist ein kugellager fahrrad und sollten
kugellager drin und hier zwischendurch
gezwungene seite durch
bild wieder selber zusammen funktioniert
weil ich hab's halt aber am pc gemacht
und jetzt habe ich habe plötzlich ein
katapult erfunden okay jetzt machen das
kugellager hereingelegt in diesen
aufsatz hier mit ein bisschen kraft
zumindest bewusst dass halter
weggeklappt ende kommt der sohn bolz
punkte auf gold und nach dem was da drin
ist heißt finger aber hin und
herrutschen das funktioniert super gut
auch richtig smith auch nicht raus das
kann man super smith hin und herbewegen
okay ich stehe jetzt bevor ich heute
schlafengehen nochmal den längsten 3d
druck meines lebens 13 stunden lang wenn
ich jetzt auf dieser fläche die ich
jetzt gleich mit kleber eindecken werde
einmal alles drucken alle teile noch mal
ein extrem hoher qualität noch mal
leicht modifiziert manchmal leicht
verbessert an ein paar stellen dicker
gemacht er ist stabiler ist wenn ich nur
sagen viel spaß mit dieser time labs die
13 14 stunden dauert
[Musik]
so jetzt wird's ernst müssen dieses
verrückte dinge hier in die tat umsetzen
und zwar einmal aufs holz drauf zahlen
im endeffekt soll das ding auch meine
skizze 16 zentimeter bereit sein dann
länger 15 zentimeter ja das ist jetzt
bisschen geschmackssache hier
[Musik]
nur eine billige metallsäge wird schon
das hat jetzt nicht so gut funktioniert
so mit der säge kann man jetzt nicht
wirklichkeitsnah so man stößt dann
irgendwann hier das drücken jetzt hatte
ich sägeblatt abgeschraubt an in der
dose wangen also es gibt einige als
quote setzt nicht das beste werkzeug wie
gesagt aber es ist ein wirklich das
beste was ich habe ne kann jetzt die
form als instrument fertig sieht
bisschen wild aus den eigentlich
bisschen aus wie die gitarre nur dass
man die halt kommen andersrum spielt
also man spielt jetzt nicht so kann man
spielt ja also und die rückseite ist
jetzt nicht so schön geworden aber wir
müssen ja uns um die geforderte kümmern
hier muss ich jetzt die löcher rein
machen
[Musik]
perfekt dieses ding ist herr ich ja es
sieht jetzt ein bisschen experimentell
aus auf der seite hier was auch fertig
ist sind mittlerweile die 3d druck da
haben wir einmal ganz viele einzelteile
die wir jetzt verbauen können und das
wird eine weile dauern
ich würde sagen wir sehen mal eine coole
montage wir können an bringen ich habe
jetzt hier zwei von diesen mechanismen
fertig der einige warte noch ein
bisschen weil der einfach kaputt
gegangen es ist druck gerade eben noch
immer müssen wir jetzt die dinge hier an
diesem ort fest machen also alles das
wird jetzt hier ein bisschen
eingezeichnet und gebohrt
[Musik]
wir kommen rein ich hoffe dass er gut
durchkommt heraus und da kann ich dann
auch ohne motor draufpacken bin ich gut
ich habe jetzt leider also da gibt es
jetzt auch wirklich dran so rum wird es
dann quasi gespielt man hat dann hier
dieses leider mit dem man dann mit drei
fingern jeweils diese einstellen ringer
verstellen kann kommt jedoch relativ gut
also das ist heute fest man kann ein
bisschen erhöhen oder irgendwo ein
bisschen abschluss mit seinem bisher nur
runder läuft aber an und für sich
funktioniert gut auch der mechanismus
bei dem man jetzt eben hier so drauf
klicken kann uns ist das retina unten
näher an den leuten zu bringen ich finde
dass es mal richtig geile immer wieder
auf die maschine und ich hab's einfach
einen 3d drucker gemacht habe richtig
bock darauf zu sehen wie das dann am
ende den ton an verändert nun fehlt aber
noch das wichtigste die seiten da sich
der prozess nun echt relativ lang
gezogen hat hatte ich doch genug zeit um
mir diese kleinen teile aus dem internet
zu bestellen für den auf ziemlich alles
muss drei teile müssen aber noch in 3d
drucker entstehen zum einen eine
auflagefläche für die seiten und zum
anderen sattel und steg so nennt man das
zumindest regale bass und gitarre jetzt
in frage wie kriegen das mega das kleine
werkzeug hier am start richtig wilder
alien so
ich habe das einmal verstärkt mit
aluminium also jetzt kann man die seiten
denke ich mal drauf zimmern das wäre
jetzt herausfinden ob das ganze experte
flop war oder auch nicht der letzte
sound man kann also das geht einmal hier
in mein gott war voll geil dass wir
durch gezogen hier drauf und dann hier
eingerichtet am besten und dann halt
aufgespannt jetzt nur das hält nicht ja
also sie haben das muss er dann wieder
zurück ich glaube er hat nämlich etwas
bewegt indem ich jetzt das hier quasi
dreh dreht sich der mechanismus und
design sind gespannt ich so jetzt ist
eine bestimmte seite
das soll ist nicht bekannt
ich glaube jetzt wenn ich die allen
seiten offen krieg dann könnte sogar
noch ein lied spielen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
us popstar geworden sie kommen dann wohl
einen tag später arbeit hat sich gelohnt
hoffe ich mal dass zwei teile gemacht
einfach nur noch hier drauf gelegt
werden müssen und dann soll das alles
funktionieren das sieht aus als würde
perfekt passen hackers als ob eine sache
total selbst ein ich habe hier so eine
kleine einsatz gelassen um hier so eine
mutter rein zu machen und die passt hier
auch wirklich absolut exakte rainer
zudem wackelt organi das hier ist ein
wunderschöner mechanismus bin ich finde
richtig hübsch geworden
oha ich mache mal noch ein kleiner
abänderungen dann muss ich halt
eigentlich nur noch was drauf spielen
können okay erstmal klassiker in jeder
kennt
[Musik]
ich habe einst gefecht noch hin
er ist und was verspricht damit halt
irgendwie schnell spielen es ist ein
saiteninstrument ich jetzt gerade spielt
die funktioniert auf jedem zeit
instrument die würden eigentlich
basically genauso auf geige oder was
oder ukulele funktionieren oder gitarre
natürlich aber andererseits sucht man
eigentlich mit der rechten hand bei
einer gitarre und nicht mit der linken
hand weswegen das schon mal komplett neu
für mich ist andererseits aber noch
nicht so einen guten ski liebe vertreter
oder so klingt hendersons freund in
dessen schieben also es geht man kann
damit auch immer musik machen habe ich
noch und zwar naja also mit ein bisschen
übung haben damit auch halbwegs was
braucht auch das spielen ich würde wenn
wir sagen es ist ein einsatz der
unterschied zwischen den dingen und eine
gitarre ist auf jeden fall deutlich
größer ist der unterschied zwischen der
ukulele untergeht so viel größer felix
hat einen relativ coolen namensvorschlag
und zwar die ukulele ich bin dann mal
weg sagt die stare nun noch besser
es war krass weil wir hier viel arbeit
ich finde die 3d gedruckten teile
richtig solide angesehen auch richtig
schick aus auch das ja also wir sind als
zum beispiel mit diesem neuen
mechanismus wenn die richtig gut der
alte ein bisschen schlechter und der ist
richtig top der funktioniert super und
ich denke wenn man das jetzt noch mal
ein bisschen überarbeiten würde hätte
man ein bisschen mit dem man aber mit
diesen übungen glaube ich echt coole
musik machen könnte okay weil der
einzelhändler spielen sonst dass es
keinen trend wenn es nicht geht
das war doch kunst also ich würde sagen
mission completed das ein hammer
instrumenten jetzt übrigens auch auf
kickstarter spaß so gut ist es dann doch
nicht wie ihr wisst war schon immer mein
traum mich selbstständig zu machen erst
mit musikvideos und als cutter und jetzt
als youtube gerade der start in die
selbständigkeit ist extrem schwierig
wenn man nicht weiß wie bei skater
unserem heutigen sponsor kann man nicht
nur fähigkeiten wie film fotografie und
produktivität lernen sondern auch lernen
wie man diese dann in seiner karriere
bündelt zum beispiel als selbständiger
zum beispiel in der klassik going
freelance sielmingen grandinger und
sachsen
was braucht ein gutes portfolio wie
vermarkte man sich selbst und wie baut
man sich im netzwerk auf das und mehr
erfahrt ihr über den link in der
beschreibung über den übrigens die
ersten 1000 von euch eine
probemitgliedschaft von schilcher prämie
bekommt es gibt keine störende werbung
stetig neue inhalte und wird einem
jahresabo kostet das ganze nur acht euro
im monat also schlag zu wenn jetzt schon
keine hinweise darauf möchte was als
nächstes kommen freut mir gerne mal auf
instagram und schreckt die stories auf
meinem fall kanal gibt es tägliche
content und aber die sagen sehen wie das
macht's gut
[Musik]